joining us from uh good morning football
one of our friends from nfl network and
of course fox sports as well
peter schrager how are you peter i'm
doing great rich awesome to hear your
voice
right back at you uh i started the show
with the
news of alex smith's release by the
washington football
team and everybody's putting him
essentially in jacksonville
connecting dots that uh urban meyer was
his utah coach and who bettered a mentor
a number one overall selection than
somebody who was drafted in that
position himself and who was
uh been a guy who helped guide patrick
mahomes to
his ascendancy uh but
does alex smith want to do that peter
the best point you can make right there
rich now is my point on good morning
football today where everyone's like
well he can be a backup to sam darnold
in new york
guys one of the reasons he's not with
washington anymore is because alex smith
still believes he can play
he wants to be the number one
quarterback and still thinks he can do
it at a high level
from what i'm hearing he and rivera got
along just
fine but the fact that taylor heineke
was handed that ball in the playoff game
i don't think alex smith was 100
on board with that he wanted to go in
that game ron rivera might have been
thinking let's do what's best for
everyone involved
based on how alex smith was hobbling
around with that calf injury in week 17
against the eagles
might not be safe for him to be on a
football field anymore but
smith in that gq article i think said a
lot and he basically was
implying that you know just because this
is a great comeback story doesn't mean
it
ends in 2020 or it ends
my days as a starter just because i'm
done in washington
i don't know i mean yeah urban makes a
lot of sense but they're going to always
want
lawrence on the field and if that was
going to be an issue in washington with
whoever it was why wouldn't that be an
issue in jacksonville i
i look at alex smith to a team where he
wants to compete for the starting job
i i totally agree peter you know like i
i'm
i just didn't think that all those
stories and that
remarkable documentary documenting his
comeback
i didn't see all those scenes where he
said you know what i want to finish my
days
uh mentoring a young kid and teeing it
up at sawgrass like i didn't i didn't
i must have missed that part you know
and and there are some other
you know the brady effect in my mind is
in full swing here
where yeah i know he's he's he's had
that awful leg
injury and he's back from it and he's
not the same i guess in that way
but you're seeing brady play till 44.
why
doesn't he have many many years left
potentially in his mind to go find a
spot with an excellent defense
that needs a quarterback that that can
actually put points on the board without
turning it over very much
uh i i i'm wondering what those teams
that he might think would want him
would be in your mind you know i look at
some of his former coaches because
that's what we obviously do and
matt maggie's name has been mentioned
the issue with the bears to me is that
the bears fans
are looking their chops for an even
bigger swing than alex smith and
whatever that may be
whether it's trading the farm for one of
the two quarterbacks that seem aggrieved
that
wilson and watson or it's a rookie or
whatever it is but
i almost fear that for for that fan base
and for that organization
alex smith is not a big enough swing for
them so
you start looking around the league and
there are some teams that need
quarterbacks like
you know is the upgrade from teddy
bridgewater and carolina i think so
could new orleans make sense
i think so i i don't think alex smith is
looking to just
hold a clipboard and like you said be
playing there's nothing against it and
chase daniel and josh mccown have made a
great career
of being awesome mentors and being
amazing in the room
and always being there for their veteran
uh you know for their young quarterbacks
drew stan and all those guys
alex smith doesn't view himself that way
he still views himself as the number one
quarterback who's gonna
who's gonna compete like helen beat you
out for the job in training camp
peter schrager here on the rich eisen
show final friday
uh of the first week of well i guess the
friday of the first week of march and
the friday
um before all the cuts are gonna happen
and then new league year begins
you mentioned two quarterbacks in the
aggrieved column do you think there's
any there there
for watson and uh wilson
with the new league year being a
deadline at all
yeah look watson had a lot of people
talking on behalf of him
whether it was every nfl reporter coming
out with the same
almost press release like report at the
same exact moment on a friday a few
months ago where
watson's unhappy and has requested a
trade whether it was jaylen ramsey on
our colleagues jim trotter and steve
weisha's podcast coming out saying i
don't think he's ever going to play for
sex again
we haven't heard from watson and i think
until watson looks at the texans and
tells them
i will never wear this jersey again and
i demand being traded
knowing knowing nick casario who just
took over at gm
and not knowing david cully that well
but knowing what he's about and a lot of
people he's worked with before
they are going to do everything in their
power to make desean watson happy and
remind him that
we're new we're fresh blood we don't we
have not we have there is no
institutional
knowledge of whatever you're upset about
that we're coming into so please give us
a shot
and i think they want to make it work
they really do if watson isn't willing
to listen it might be time
to to answer some of those calls but as
of right now the texans are
are held and i've spoken to a lot of
teams who are like of course we want to
sean watson and it's
i don't think it's news that teams have
been calling for a show a lot that the
texans won't even listen to offers when
did that change
as for wilson anytime i see an agent on
the record
with adam schefter offer four teams that
he would consider going to i mean
that makes it pretty serious and you've
been hearing about a rift between
seattle and wilson for some time it's
not the money he doesn't want more money
so that to me does give me a bit of an
alarm and
you know the nfl is so weird right now
that i wouldn't be shocked if either guy
we wake up on monday and is like got a
new team it's just
this is what it feels like it's become
the nba and
the same breath that tom brady can leave
the patriots and go to
tampa bay walk russell wilson demand a
trade and be traded somewhere else and
be starting for another team next year
no i know everybody's looking at tom and
saying why not me
i i guess in in in all of that regard
and
maybe watson has communicated that to
the texans
because we found out about what a week
later that he did in fact
tell them i want to trade uh then it
came out publicly
and then uh we found out days after he
did have a conversation
reportedly with david cully that he did
actually have that conversation
you know he's not out there pounding his
chest
and he and the texans are
just one send button
or phone call to a member of the nfl
media
buy desean watson away from having this
whole entire thing spin out of control
so has it has it not spun out of control
yet i ask you as someone who does a
daily show it's kind of good for us in
the media because it's a dead time and a
lot of
you know without the combine we've
started every show on good morning
football maybe the past two weeks with a
desean watson conversation and the fans
love it because
you start doing the photoshops in your
head and if you're a jets fan
it's mesmerized if you're a bears fan
it's mesmerizing if you're a 49ers fan
you start thinking about them with your
team today nate burleson dropped when
he's like look didn't casario used to
work
for the patriots would this not be the
ultimate gift to
his former team and would that not be
the big swing and it's like
i'm not gonna i'm not gonna discount
that and say it's impossible anything is
so you know the texans saying we're not
listening to phone calls that's great
until free agency starts filling out and
the draft starts showing up and suddenly
all those open quarterback spots are
filled
and you're left with aj mccarron week
one and you're fining desean watson two
million dollars a day because
he's not showing up to camp no look you
know i and i just
you you just need to look at teams who
have the capital to do it
um and are close enough to the
second overall pick to do it if it's not
the
team that actually holds it with the
jets or the team that actually holds the
texans
former first overall pick in the
dolphins
right you got carolina that's
potentially close i don't know the bears
would literally have to maybe include
the lease
to soldier field um yeah and
i said i said it on good morning
football i'm like it would take the 20th
it would also take roquan smith it would
take khalil mack and it would probably
take eddie jackson and
pick any offensive players take three or
four and i still don't even know if
that's enough you know no i know
whereas the jets and the dolphins and at
least carolina have draft capital right
now
and the jets and dolphins could be
played off of one another to really get
it through the roof but
it doesn't seem that this is anywhere
close and that's where the draft is
going to come in i guess
peter schrager of good morning football
here on the rich odds and show turning
to the draft
uh right now um is there any
there there that trevor lawrence isn't
the first overall selection right i mean
that's
i i know there's been a ton of zack
wilson love uh
chris sims uh a colleague of ours here
on nbc sports on peacock putting him
above trevor lawrence on his list and
he's been
a lot of hits rather than misses in in
pegging
uh quarterback draft classes what do you
think
what are you hearing anything yeah i
said that uh this week
numerous times that if you want to
attack chris since his
credibility when it comes to
quarterbacks go look at him talking
about lamar jackson when the rest of us
were like he might be a first round pick
and he was saying he's the best in the
class or
mahomes couple years back so chris's
credibility is unquestioned
that's his board you know i think urban
meyer took the job in jacksonville and
from all the knowledge i have with the
assumption that he's got
you know trevor lawrence as his
quarterback i also think we start
getting a fatigue and a malaise in the
draft world
where we've had trevor lawrence as the
number one prospect for three years
we've still got five weeks to go we
gotta talk about something zack wilson
is viewed very highly by a lot of these
teams in fact i've had teams say he does
a lot of things that trevor lawrence
cannot i can't
find a team that says zach wilson is
better than trevor lawrence or
would be my pick at number one overall
that's nothing against wilson
if you want to do a wilson verse borough
comparison if you want to do a wilson
verse
um a first baker comparison we could do
that but
the trevor lawrence thing this is andrew
luck this is peyton manning this is john
elway this is that number one overall
pick
that everyone has been looking at for
years and you can't really poke a hole
in six foot six 220 pounds
and runs like a gazelle i would be
shocked shocked if you didn't go first
overall but i don't
spite anyone who says hey wilson's more
my cup of tea in today's nfl
well we're talking about you know
obviously the quarterbacks at the top of
the draft you're even hearing about
jamar chase you're hearing about this uh
this kid pits the tight end that's
supposed to be
all that plus the biscuit uh i've got
quetti pay
of my alma mater coming on in hour
number two what does the defensive side
of the draft look like right now
as you're seeing yeah not to be not to
be uh negative towards clinton
the word is on this draft top ten
prospects mostly offensive so
you're you're going a guy like that who
might be in the 10 to the 20s michael
parsons from penn state might be a top
10 guy
um fairly the the cornerback from from
virginia tech is highly regarded
morig the safety from tcu i can lift
names that are highly regarded
for rich there is no chase young in this
draft there is no mild garrett in this
draft there is no slam dunk
this guy's a generational you know
player on defense coming
out of college they might end up being
that but right now
it's it's a very interesting draft that
and i don't know if it's because
some of these guys didn't play or the
weird college season but just from what
you're hearing from teams
good quarterbacks nothing great beyond
trevor lawrence and zach wilson you're
looking at lance and fields and of
course
you know mac jones and um the young man
from texas a m but i you know receivers
tight ends offensive linemen i don't
have that pass rusher off the edge that
everyone
calling me up and saying oh have you
watched a jalen phillips miami tape
uh you have to because he's that guy and
i could tell you and you know this in
years past we've heard about isaiah
simmons and derek brown where
chase young's not the guy but this one
might be you know whatever it is that
doesn't exist this year so
your guy out of michigan could be the
first offensive player taken in this
draft i wouldn't be shocked because i
don't have a single player
that's that home run hall of fame
candidate buzz type guy so having the
second overall pick like the jets
uh for instance um when
zack wilson is either quarterback
1a or two um
they can really make some hay out of
this sort of thing here right i mean
like this is
this is significant and what are you
hearing from joe douglas
uh uh or out of the jets camp because
again i know this is not just it's not
just a question for me and all the
people who root for the same team that i
root for
but where the jets go uh with either
wilson makes
darnold available or if they stick with
darnold that makes
the second overall selection available
and if they get desean watson i mean
holy cow
what that would mean writ large for
everybody else in this pond
in the nfl what do you think the jets
are doing
at two if we're all assuming it's
jacksonville and it's
it's uh trevor lawrence and urban meyer
uh hitched which is exactly why urban
took the job
yeah look it's no secret i i'll say it
i'm friendly with robert sala we talk
pretty often
i'm i'm also friendly with christopher
johnson who who runs the team and i know
joe douglas very well
i can be completely honest with you that
they don't know yet and they're fine
with that they actually like where
they're at really
at this point in the process because
they're doing the work but also
as this zack wilson buzz continues to
build and whether it's from them
or the or the christians or the media
folk
that's all good that only helps the jets
of the number two overall pick
and the same breath they're getting to
know sam darnold and
they're probably listening to some of
the things that are being said and you
know what
sam donald's a pretty good option for a
lot of these teams as well if they were
to move on from sam darnold and trade
him
you look at i think a solid six to seven
teams that would view sam darnold as a
very very solid upgrade from what they
have right now
and a veteran quarterback if the jets
were to go number two so they're doing
their work
i can tell you they really do like sam
darnold a lot but this zach wilson buzz
does not hurt the jets in any way if
anything
it helps them and it's a they can't lose
you either have darnold
and this really valuables number two
overall pick or you go with zach wilson
and you could trade darnold and get some
stuff in return
so are any quarterbacks gonna move what
do you think you know in the minute
and and and then there's the the whole
drew brees
um deal why hasn't he retired i've asked
that question of
multiple people this week i'll i'll give
you the uh
the floor on that one what about that i
was pounding my my
my my system on my table and good
morning football saying this is a this
is a story
you know k adams was sort of like oh
come on he's likely retiring pam jordan
wouldn't
wouldn't be talking about russell wilson
publicly if we didn't know drew was
retiring and then
kind of nate and kyle were we're
agreeing with her and i'm like
why is he retired there's no rhyme or
reason there's no rhyme or reason why he
wouldn't just have a wonderful press
conference
and say i'm done unless he's still
thinking it over it would do the same
a great service to finally be able to
move on and turn the page
and i think it would also do uh drew a
great service and now be able to move on
and experience no
he hasn't decided yet to me it's the
it's the oddest thing because
rich we've been doing this for a long
time and you know that when peyton
manning
scheduled that press conference three
days after the season or eli manning has
that that instagram post it's like
it's a really good time it's a great
opportunity to celebrate these men and
kind of wish them off and drew we're now
in march the only other comparison i
have is far
and it ended ugly and weird in green bay
yeah it is march
maybe it's next week right when um
because because new league years coming
up we we got to know before then right
don't you think they need to know like
because then you have this other thing
what if
and this is where you could have a
full-on hour-long debate
what if drew calls up sean payton and
says okay one more year
are the saints better off with drew
brees or starting with some other
quarterback at this point i would say
you never get rid of a drew brees and
that you take him
as long as he wants to go you ride with
him but there are some voices who would
say gosh
maybe give james the reigns or maybe
even go and get a different quarterback
and maybe get a different result than
we've had the last few years at the end
of the playoffs
last one for you cuts give me some names
um
we're hearing uh half the league pretty
much right
it's just insane what what what uh what
i'm hearing you know ear to ground
but when do these things happen next
week is that when it all goes down
next week what you're going to see over
the next few days a lot of players
restructuring their contracts
and what that means is instead of me
making 12 million this year i'll make 8
million and i just want to keep a job
it's going to be a bloodbath i think
rich
and it's not fun to talk about because
right these are players that you know
it's not going to be the young
free agent wide receiver it's going to
be some players that are solid number
two wide outs in this league
and solid number two defensive end that
you love as players on your team that
simply make too much money and if
they're not willing to restructure and
take a pay cut it looks like they're
gone
and it doesn't it's not fair it's
ridiculous actually but
guess what this is the economic times
we're dealing with and the middle class
that's what i call it
the veteran player who already has made
some money
that guy is at a serious serious danger
right now as we head into
salary cap hell and cutting seasons
peter you're the man thanks for
uh thanks rately for for joining us on
the friday and uh
and we'll we'll get you back on uh as
much as you'd like over the next few
weeks
certainly leading up to the draft where
it looks like we're going to be in ohio
together
so uh i look forward to that i hope so
my friend and man did i miss you in
indianapolis till next year
right back at you thank you that's uh
peter schrager everybody here
on the rich eisen show hey you watched
all the way to the end thanks for that
watch more right here